I said I want leakin greetings of peace
you want to see something amazing look
look look look it's an apple who put it
there who put all these fruits on the
trees the vegetables in the ground for
us it's not coincidence that is there in
the earth for us to feed us have we
given thanks today to the Almighty we
take a lot of these things for granted
but what if they weren't there what if
the the simplest thing that's on the
earth for us water if we didn't have it
how much would we give of all our
possessions to just have one sip of
water king was asked if there was no
water in your kingdom this King had
everything what would you give for the
last glass of water in your kingdom he
said I give half my kingdom and then he
said what if you couldn't go to the
bathroom to get this liquid out after
you drank the water he said I'd give
another at the other half of my kingdom
look his whole kingdom revolved around
those two blessings of Allah the food
the drink and the health next time you
want to pick up highly toxic food that
tastes good a snicker bar coca-cola
potato chips highly processed brought
any kind of processed junk food you
think about the vehicle that's going to
get you through life and that's your
body fifty percent of people living
today will have cancer and one of the
contributing forces is the food the
toxic fools that we're putting and drink
into our bodies and if you can make a
difference by eliminating these things
you know that you can decrease your
chances increase thirty percent of
catching diabetes by just drinking pops
and so does now you can eliminate that
why wouldn't you by next time you have a
little craving for some sweet you want
to reward your children rewarding with
an apple a date a banana a real food and
see the benefits start to blossom and
bless by you appreciating this blessing
that Allah has given a
being thankful and grateful this is one
of the keys to living a successful life
to appreciating the blessings being
thankful for and also preserving the
blessings and one of the great blessings
that we have is our health be conscious
of it protected thank you guys for
spending those few mins with me I hope
you enjoy Salaam alaikum to epcot peace
be with you